buying fake vaccine cards violates the  law that by definition means you are not  law abiding making and selling fake  vaccine cards violates the law that by  definition means you are not law abiding  now tucker has talked about this before  about people who get fake papers to go  someplace that they wouldn't otherwise  be allowed  but he wasn't calling them law abiding  then  he was sort of using more muted language  now he's just going and saying it it's  it's the trump thing of what you're  seeing with your own eyes you can't or  shouldn't believe  these are law abiding but they're  committing a crime they're breaking a  law here's the law that they are  breaking but these are decent  law-abiding people this is really scary  stuff and of course it's only going to  encourage more of it  now with joe biden's federal employee  vaccine requirement i can only imagine  that these people are going to go  absolutely crazy